la parole est maintenant notre collègue
claude nougein pour le groupe l'est
républicain avait la mer rouge merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
la bonne nouvelle est arrivée le chômage
est tombé à 6% atteignant le plus le
taux le plus bas depuis 25 ans ne rêvez
pas mes chers collègues
il s'agit d' allemagne mais également de
la grande bretagne des états unis
l'espagne aussi amorce une décrue la
france est un des seuls pays d'europe ou
de fromage progresse pourquoi
tout simplement car nous récoltons ce
que vous avez semé
nos récoltes fiscale nos recettes
fiscales atteignent désormais 46 % du
pib selon l' ocde 10 points au-dessus de
la moyenne des pays riches la france et
vice-champion du monde en matière
d'impôts est ce un hasard
j'en doute car la folie fiscale 2012 sur
les entreprises et les ménages a
totalement paralysé l'économie française
par des artifices coûteux via des
emplois publics financés à crédit
la courbe du chômage va probablement
s'inverser en 2016
je fais confiance à l'habileté politique
du président de la république nous avons
été élus de nombreuses années au sein du
même département
mais malheureusement son habileté ne
coûtera rien à long terme
pourquoi investir en france au foie zir
de construire une usine en france quand
le taux d'impôt des sociétés 33 % et 25
% en moyenne dans l'europe
quand le taux d'impôt sur les revenus
des capitaux agrémenter la csg le plus
haut d'europe quand les ss impôt unique
au monde sur les capitaux des
actionnaires dont dirigeants
d'entreprises familiales pour chaque
jour avant les entreprises à des groupes
étrangers
quand l'interprétation du code du
travail est plus aléatoire encore que le
code du travail lui-même les mesures
annoncées hier matin par le président de
la république ne sont que des
demi-mesures qui continuent contre les
réalités alors monsieur le premier
ministre la question et précise quand
prendrez-vous carli urgent d'agir des
mesures structurelles identique aux
autres pays européens pour que la france
soit ramené galles et revient dans le
pôle tentait d économie mondiale je
crois que pour vous répondre la parole
et à christian eckert jeu réd elle était
en charge du budget vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
votre question pose essentiellement la
question de la fiscalité il est bon de
rappeler un certain nombre de réalités
certains s'en plaignent d'autres le
trouvent insuffisant mais la baisse de
la pression fiscale et sociale sur les
entreprises est une vraie réalité pour
ce gouvernement
vous parlez du cic le cicr apporte une
réduction d'impôt pour les entreprises
là encore certains le dénonce de l'ordre
de 18 milliards d'euros par an les
cotisations sociales dans le cadre du
pacte de responsabilité
une première tranche en 2015 une seconde
en 2016 apporte une réduction des
contributions sociales des employeurs de
l'ordre de 7 milliards d'euros nous
allons alléger les cotisations sociales
des travailleurs indépendants d'un
milliard d'euros nous avons mis fin à la
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
grandes entreprises créées d'ailleurs je
crois par monsieur fillon pour environ
2,5 milliards d'euros
nous avons modifié les seuils des pme
pour l'application d'insolente de
contribution pour plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros
allez j'ai allégé l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour les entreprises qui
investissent avec eux sur amortissements
pour environ 500 millions d'euros par an
alors ça suffit ça suffit de dire que ce
gouvernement écraserait les entreprises
d'impôts ce gouvernement a entamé une
réduction d'impôt pour les entreprises
je pèse mes mots inégalé depuis une
décennie inégalé pour une décennie alors
monsieur sénateurs il vous reste si j'ai
bien compté environ une vingtaine de
secondes pour me décrire les mesures
structurelles que vous souhaitez présent
ap
merci
pour 12 secondes
monsieur le ministre tous les pays où on
voit et on constate une baisse du
chômage importante n'ont pas créé le cic
eux ils n'ont pas créé tout ce que vous
avez créés ils ont simplement appliqué
la même méthode d impôt sur les sociétés
plus léger et moins de contraintes
cela suffit il faut pas inventer
n'importe quoi